¿Cuáles de los siguientes triángulos son
similares al triángulo ABC?
Nos dan todas estas opciones y veamos.
Este es el triángulo que nos preguntan,
¿cuáles de estas opciones son similares a éste ABC?
Recordemos a qué nos referimos
con triángulos similares.
Si yo tengo dos triángulo, por ejemplo... éste de acá...
y tengo otro triángulo...
más o menos así...
me quedó un poco chico, el espacio...
pero bueno...
Si yo tengo estos dos triángulos,
que se ven a primera vista, pues diferentes, éste
es más grande que éste.
2 triángulos serán similares, si y solo si,   todos los ángulos internos correspondientes son iguales,
o congruentes.
Qué quiere decir, que si tengo este ángulo
de acá y es igual a este ángulo de acá
y además tengo este ángulo de acá
igual a este ángulo de acá
y finalmente este ángulo de acá
es igual a este ángulo de acá,
todos los ángulos internos correspondientes
son congruentes, entonces estos dos triángulos
van a ser similares... similares.
Cuando tenemos triángulos similares, la proporción
de los lados van a ser iguales entre sí.
Imaginen que este lado de acá...
que este lado de acá que estoy señalando
en rosa, mide 2 y el lado de aquí abajito,
éste de aquí mide 1.
Bueno, esta proporción 2 a 1 de este triángulo,
también se va a tener en este triángulo más grande.
Supongamos que este lado de acá,
que estoy señalando, mide 3...
y el lado correspondiente, aquí abajo,
éste de acá,  mide 1.5,
sigue siendo la misma proporción
2 a 1, así que estos dos son similares,
sus ángulos internos correspondientes son iguales
y la proporción entre sus lados también va a ser igual.
Bueno, ya que recordamos esto,
ahora vamos a verlo aplicado acá
y analizando cada una
de estas opciones, veamos.
Nuestra primera opción es el triángulo AGD,
vamos a marcarlo,
el triángulo... A...
G... D...
Bueno, pues de entrada podemos ver que estos dos
triángulos son similares, de hecho comparten
dos lados, o sea esta hipotenusa y este lado
y bueno, vemos que este otro lado es paralelo a éste.
Entonces estos triángulos sí son similares,
esta opción sí es.
Ahora, veamos la siguiente, CEF,
vamos a marcarlo en otro color...
C... E, hasta acá... y F...
Bueno, ese triángulo, no es similar,  ¿por qué?
Recordemos que la pendiente de
una recta va a ser constante
y cualquier triángulo rectángulo
que se forme con cualquier par de puntos sobre
esta recta va a tener la misma proporción,
es decir también va a tener la misma pendiente.
Recordemos que la pendiente es la diferencia
en "y" con respecto a la diferencia en "x".
Nuestros triángulos ABC, este es un triángulo
rectángulo, aquí hay un ángulo recto.
Éste otro, en la opción que vimos AGD, también
lo es, esta línea es perfectamente horizontal
y ésta de aquí es perfectamente vertical,
pero esta C, E, F, aquí no tenemos un triángulo
rectángulo, este es un ángulo que se nota
que es mayor a 90 grados.
Así que aquí no hay similitud, éste no aplica.
Veamos el siguiente, CDG...
CDG...
éste de acá, éste de acá y éste de acá.
Y pues lo mismo que en el anterior caso,
no tenemos un triángulo rectángulo aquí,
esta línea no es para nada vertical,
así que este es un ángulo menor a 90 grados y aquí
tampoco va a aplicar la similitud,
veamos la tercera opción.
Triángulo DEF, veamos.
D, es un punto que está aquí sobre la línea...
E, esta es una línea vertical por completo...
F y esa línea es horizontal.
Así que en este triángulo de acá,
si se está formando un ángulo recto,
acá, de 90 grados.
Y tenemos dos puntos que están sobre esta
línea, cuya pendiente es constante.
Entonces ese triangulito de aquí, es similar
a este triangulote de acá
y a éste que nos indicaban originalmente.
Éste si cumple con las reglas de similitud.
De todas maneras vamos a recordar un poco
de las clases de álgebra,
sobre las líneas paralelas y las transversales, por ejemplo, esta línea de acá del segmento DE,
que lo voy a hacer un poquito más grande, de aquí
a acá, esta línea la podemos ver como línea
paralela al segmento AB o incluso al segmento
AG, la voy a marcar también aquí...
de aquí a acá las extiendo para que se note
que son líneas paralelas.
Y podemos ver esta línea, nuestra línea
recta azul como una transversal a estas líneas
paralelas y recordemos que los ángulos que
se forman en líneas paralelas por una transversal,
van a ser ángulos iguales, así que el ángulo
formado entre esta línea y ésta,
es igual al ángulo formado entre esta línea y ésta,
estos dos son iguales,
de hecho le pongo doble marca para que se note que son iguales estos dos.
Lo mismo de este otro lado, si yo tengo esta
línea de acá, que incluye al segmento EF...
la voy a extender, esta línea así...
y esta otra línea, del segmento BC,
de aquí a acá, estas son líneas paralelas
y de nuevo mi recta es la transversal,
así que el ángulo que se forma entre estas líneas paralelas azules y esta transversal
va a tener la misma medida.
Entonces este ángulo de acá...
le pongo con tres marquitas...
es igual a este ángulo de acá... con tres marquitas...
y bueno, ya habíamos quedado
que estas de acá son ángulos rectos,
éste de acá y éste de acá que apenas se nota.
Así que estos tienen ángulos internos correspondientes
iguales, por lo tanto son triángulos similares.
Ahora veamos si ésta es la respuesta correcta.
Ok, aquí está la pantalla en el portal de
Khan Academy, de ejercicios de esta sección
y seleccionamos esta primera opción y la
última opción que eran las que nosotros
encontramos como correctas, éstas dos.
Y ahora veamos si de verdad
estuvo bien nuestro análisis.
Comprobar respuesta... y... carita feliz, ¡muy bien!
Eso estuvo bien realizado,
nos vemos en el siguiente video.